gorgeous by the way thank you trihard
you do you I do I try so I'll you know I
just did the roast of Bruce Willis and
heard about this yeah in it you know
they say some really mean stuff and I've
done one of the roasts before and and I
knew going into this Willis roast that
they like the first roast I did they
called me they say if you're a woman
that you either say old fat or ugly and
so they called me a horse face a lot or
maybe they said I had a horse face but I
don't know sir let's hope it's horrid
space because that's the thing is like I
also have a reputation as like a sex
comic so I was like oh they're gonna
call me like a [ __ ] which I'm not I
they can say that but I'm not a dumb
[ __ ] I was in AP English so I know but
yeah they went after me and said some
things that hurt and and it affected my
self-esteem a little bit I mean I think
it looks like Owen will you know all
this stuff gets to me I did and I was um
I didn't do some jokes that I wanted to
do what that I would like to share and
it defeats the purpose of the fact that
I didn't do it but I didn't do it that
night because um well I was gonna say I
feel close to Bruce Willis because I
feel like I look just off enough to
maybe be one of his daughters and I mean
that in like we're so almost hot like
we're so close to hot we're hot but
we're not just like we are our dad's DNA
won out over
[Laughter]
and everyone's like you can't say that
to them and I'm like they're hot and and
I'm saying I'm one of them like we're so
close and and because we're not totally
hot we have personalities so thank God
yeah humor yes it's because I was thank
you for confirming it's true you have to
have struggles is when you're as a youth
when you're if you're good-looking
people when I see someone who's
good-looking and they're funny it
infuriates me I know they think you
don't get to have both you shouldn't and
I was like a gross child like I was
really I had a really beautiful sister
and everywhere my mom took us people
would stop my mom and be like this child
needs to be a model about my sister and
I would literally like creep from behind
my mom's legs like Nosferatu like so
gross and they would always try to be
nice and they'd be like oh and you
should be a model train enthusiast or
learnis
you